[Musique]
paris
la cimade eux
organisée conjointement par le cdas
l'académie d'art et donc nous allons
vous trouvez cette harmonie des tous
meilleurs élèves dans quelques ap en cm
1 4102 les 4 millions 6e pour chacune
des manches
il y aura ainsi qu'à sion 3 calcul
automatisée avec dix secondes de
réflexion il y aura deux calculs
réfléchi avec vingt secondes de
réflexion et l'activité montag se
déroulera soit ordinateur avec 30
secondes de réflexion je souhaite un bon
courage à tous les élèves présents
aujourd'hui
alors la première manche chez les cm1 va
démarrer maintenant je laisse ces deux
candidats se présenter à l'école la
conscience hoffman bonjour je m'appelle
c'est pas bien de ma vie je suis en
scène et je suis
[Musique]
merci à tous les deux
et bonne chance donc nous t'aimons la
planche alors on va commencer d'abord
pas de calcul automatisé vous avez trois
exercices premier exercice 54,9 -33
diagne 7,54 c'est une bonne réponse tu
marches un point deuxième exercice 28
plus 75 + 22 + 25 28 +75 troisième
exercice donne le triple de 1700 donne
le trip de 1700 alors donc on enchaîne
avec la deuxième partie calcul réfléchit
donc vous pouvez prendre vos stylos go
ainsi brûler s'ils pas une obligation
premier problème
chloé a préparé 48 pot de confiture de
goya liés elle donne 16 po à alexandre
puis 14 peau à anna
combien de pots de confiture lui
reste-t-il
vite 18 quoi c'est très bien tu marques
un point deuxième problème
un bateau quitte la réunion à 22h et
arrive le lendemain matin à 10h à
maurice quelle a été la durée de la
traversée
alors nous allons maintenant sur la
troisième d'un pull automatisé dans
chaque site et mentale donc il avoue
être projeté ici sur l'écran vous allez
bien vous regardez vous avez trente
secondes pour donner la réponse à mon
signal c'est parti
[Musique]
ce n'est pas la bonne taille
ce n'est pas non plus la bonne réponse
aurait dû réfléchir de compte en tirer
le temps la bonne réponse est sans
regarder vous avez 36 49 64 81 36 6 x 6
49 7 x 7 64 il faut à 8 95 x 9 et 10
choisissent sa descente
donc bravo chloé histoire qui qualifié
pour l'étape suivante et mat il faudra
vous aussi à toi qui n'as pas des braves
alors maintenant nous allons donc
enchaîner avec la deuxième manche dans
la catégorie cm1 et donc je vais
demander aux deux élèves présents de se
présenter
je suis enseignant à l'école des bassins
de soldats merci à tous les deux et
votre chance
selon démarrer tout de suite avec les
calculs alors premiers calculs 90e 4 +
67 81,4 très longue deuxième calcul
donne le tiers de 4500 12 donnes le
tiers de 4500 12
malheureusement le temps une personne a
trouvé la bonne réponse
le tiers de 4512 donc la bonne réponse
et 1504 vous pouvez décomposée en deux
étapes le fier de 4500 et le tiers de 12
d'accord donc le tir de quatre mille
cinq cent mille 500 de tir de 12 après
quatre et ont trouvé la réponse
c'est pas grave on continue avec donc le
troisième quelque troisième calcule
combien y at il de mettre dans 3,50 deux
kilomètres alors deuxième partie calcul
réfléchi premiers calculs le tigre d'un
zoo mange 8 kg par jour son soigneur a
chuté 88 kg de viande pendant combien de
jours pourra-t-il nourrir le tigre
[Musique]
on passe à la deuxième problème théo
distribuer 2 litres de jus de fruits il
veut à ce 25 centilitres dans chacun des
six verres dont il dispose
combien de santi litres de jus
reste-t-il dans la bouteille
théo distribuer 2 litres de jus de
fruits ilves 25 centilitres dans chacun
des six verres dont il dispose
combien de centilitres
[Musique]
50 centilitres bravo c'est la bonne
réponse alors on va enchaîner maintenant
sur la démarcation donc il va être une
activité mentale
vous avez aussi droit de prendre des
notes en cours l'activité mentale elle
va durer et 30 secondes séparent
[Musique]
car à quelques semaines bravo c'est la
bonne réponse alors le score final
bravo à tous les deux merci alors nous
voilà prêts donc pour la troisième
manche et les cm1 et donc nous
retrouvons chloé voiliers de l'école de
la confiance à sainte marie nous
retrouverons mais près de l'école des
bassins également à sa part est ce que
vous êtes prêts tous les deux
oui eh bien on va démarrer avec les
véhicules premiers calculs entre
parenthèses 13,7 plus 5,3 x 4 2e calcul
2400 / 5 2400 divisé par cinq
480 bravo c'est la bonne réponse tu
marques un point supplémentaire
troisième calcule combien y at-il de
minutes dans 1800 secondes
combien y at-il de minutes
combien y at-il de minutes dans 1800
seconde niveau des problèmes je vous
rappelle que je dois prendre des notes
et donc on démarre le premier calcul
tous premiers calculs l'aspirine est un
médicament qui existe depuis 1853
depuis combien d'années l'aspirine
existe-t-elle
l'aspirine est un média
l'aspirine est un médicament qui existe
depuis 1853
depuis combien d'années l'aspirine
existe-t-elle
deuxième problème lors d'une sortie on
souhaite distribuer trois biscuits à
chacun des 24 élèves de la classe
les biscuits sont vendus par paquets de
douze combien de paquets
faut-il acheter bravo c'est la bonne
réponse dans un mois
alors on va maintenant terminée on parle
activités montagne donc trente secondes
de réflexion vous avez le droit de
prendre des notes
c'est parti
bravo c'est la bonne
alors le score final
[Musique]
bravo employés s'est terminée pour les
cme donc c'est chloé qui remporte donc
la grande finale des cm1 pour 2017
alors cette première manche et laisser
mourir maintenant commencer donc nous
deux élèves vont se présenter
bonjour vous m'avez rivières le chien je
suis en cm2 et je suis à l'école des
bassins à sainte-marie applications
c'est près tous les deux avec les
parties pour les calculs automatisé donc
là un premier calcul 236 8 - 30 sept
[Musique]
ce n'est pas le moment et font souple la
bonne réponse 299,8 deuxième calcul 13 x
13 3e calcul entre parenthèses 151 +49
divisé par dix
enfin la deuxième partie maintenant les
problèmes calcul réfléchir vous pouvez
prendre vos stylos si vous voulez
premiers calculs martin participent à
une épreuve de ski de fond de 8 5 km de
long
à midi il lui reste 3,75 qui le met à
parcourir
quelle distance at il déjà parcouru
bravo c'est la bonne réponse
martin points deuxième problème si
ballon de football coûte 180 euros
combien coûte 5 ballons six ballons de
football côte-d'or
c'est la bonne réponse tu marques un
point va enchaîner avec le dernier
problème donc j'ai fait une activité
mentale donc sur les grands vous allez
avoir trente secondes de réflexion c'est
parti
[Musique]
et le temps est écoulé ici il fallait
repérer on a donc très vite habitants il
fallait opérer plus la zone coloriée
correspondent car comme c'est le cas du
thar de 13,8 d'accord et donc le quart
de 13,8 qui va faire après vingt trois
mille deux cent cinquante habitants
[Musique]
bravo à tous les deux cas merci
alors nous allons donc démarrer cette
deuxième manche et vaisselle 2 et je
vais d'abord demandé une canne deux
candidats de se présenter aux journaux
tels que ça peut se targuer j'ai dix ans
et je suis ancien bloc de la mare à
l'entre-deux bonjour je m'appelle dit si
bono nous tiens j'ai dix ans
[Musique]
merci à tous les deux vous êtes prêts on
va compter marc et parfois quelques
automatismes premiers calculs 147,7 +54
647,7 plus 54,6 dix années de lecture
on en a oublié quelque chose de son 2.3
deuxième calcul 714 / cette troisième
calcul entre parenthèses 158,3 moins 35
x 10 entre parenthèses 158,3 moins 35 x
10 et non il fallait prendre tu avais de
réfléchir puisque
non le temps de réfléchir
la bonne réponse était l'île de son
contrat à la deuxième partie là vous
pouvez prendre des notes
premier problème en moyenne un français
jette 0,35 tonnes de déchets par an
calculant tonnes la quantité moyenne de
déchets produits en un an pour une
famille française de quatre personnes en
moyenne un français jette en moyenne un
français jeunes 0,30 c'est dommage il y
avait la réponse ne confondez pas
deuxième problème un rectangle mesure 6
mètres de longueur et à un périmètre de
18 mètres calcule son air en mètres
carrés un rectangle mais gir 6 mètres de
longueur et un périmètre de 18 mètres
calcule son air en mètres carrés
ce n'est pas la bonne réponse donc ici
la bonne réponse était 18 mètres carrés
donc déjà il va falloir calculer la
largeur ou ce qu'on a que la longueur
qui 2,6 m le périmètre est de 18 mètres
la largeur et 2 3 m après l'ère du
rectangle longueur x largeur donc 6 x 3
18 donc 18 mètres carrés
on va enchaîner maintenant sur une
activité montag et l'avoir en 30
secondes de réflexion vous pouvez bien
sûr prendre des notes et ça va être
projeté sur l'écran de l'ordinateur
sépare
dans des gobelets malheureusement il ya
une souffrance d'accord alors je vais
donner l'explication on vous parlait de
48 jeux hélas si vous l'avez sur l'écran
il ya combien de l'autorité sont
présents en france
oui il ya six jeux tout cas si je tombe
ici présents ou par rapport à 48 sél
huit fois moins et donc il fallait après
ces 72 / lui faisait à 9 d'accord vous
êtes embarqué dans des méthodes je pense
plus compliqué ça donc on va prendre le
score final mais voilà on arrive donc à
la finale des cm2 entre nil et thibault
est ce que tu es 12 après un premier
exercice entre parenthèses 455 plus 45 /
entre parenthèses 1,5 plus 2,5 entre
parenthèses 455 plus 45 / entre
parenthèses 1,5 +25
sous 25 c'est la bonne réponse tu
m'offres en droit interne forêt contrôle
ils ont le temps de réfléchir aux conti
deuxième exercice
combien font perdre cinquième de cent
[Musique]
troisième exercice
11h50 - 3h55 met donc le ton quand même
c'est de justesse le point accordé
lescure fait comme ça pour les autres
problèmes donc on va passer maintenant
la deuxième partie calcul réfléchi
premier problème
un éleveur a compté 120 pâte dans son
élevage
il sait qu'il a 20 lapin combien de
poule pour cette île un éleveur a compté
très bien normand deuxième problème
lily prépare un cocktail
elle mélange 2 litres de jus d'orange 1
litre 5 de jus d'ananas 4 litres de jus
de fraise et 10 centilitres de sirop de
menthe
combien de verres de 25 centilitres
peut-elle servir à ses invités lits
libres et par un cocktail
elle mélange 2 litres de jus d'orange 1
litre 5 de judo dana 4 litres de jus de
fraise et 10 centilitres de sirop de
menthe
combien de verres de 25 centilitres
[Musique]
peut-elle servir à ses invités
le temps il voulait donc la bonne
réponse ici c'était 30 verre en fait il
fallait jadis youn et les différents
ingrédients donc de litres de jus
d'orange plus sérieuse simply de judée
la sata iii et demi plus 4 litres de jus
de fraise on est à cet ennemi plus et 10
anti de sirop de menthe et en fait
qu'ils vont passer par les branches was
on arrive à 7,6 litres et après donc il
faut 7,6 la savane à 4 565 litres et
voir combien de fois il ya 25
centilitres à l'intérieur et donc ça
fait trente verts eelv a même rester
pour information 10 centilitres de trois
chacun de plus l'activité mentale on va
vous proposer maintenant est
déterminante
vous avez droit de prendre des notes et
vous avez trente secondes de réflexion
c'est parti
21 cm ce n'est pas la bonne adresse
cinq des vingt sept
ce n'est pas non plus la bonne réponse
donc la réponse ici c'était 28 cm alors
regardez le rectangle devant vous
pourriez qu'il va être composée de six
segments ici de la belle longueur
puisque la longueur est constitué de
deux segments identique donc on va être
divisé par deux parce ici on va trouver
donc 7 cm et après le crédit car et
c'est à côté d'un 4 x 7 ce qui fait une
28 centimes d'accord comme dit à égalité
on va essayer avec une question
subsidiaire
ce sera un calcul précisé vous n'avez
pas le droit de prendre de notes ça va
durer dix secondes et donc le premier
pour la bonne réponse va gagner le
concours
alors quel est le quadruple de 9,5
quel est le quadruple de 9,5
bravo c'est la bonne réponse double vice
champion et le shopping niveau de
félicitations à tous les deux
alors cette première manche 10e va
maintenant commencer
et donc je vais vous demander à tous les
deux vous présente je m'appelle mat
auber tôt je suis ok je suis en 6e au
collège des aigrettes à saint paul les
deux alors les partenaires sur les
automatismes pour l'exercice 963 diviser
par trois la bonne réponse tu as marqué
deuxième calcul 93,7 plus 8,02 -2 93,7
plus 8,02 moins deux troisièmes calcul
1357 - 399
[Musique]
ce n'est pas non plus la bonne réponse
ici la bonne réponse était 958 l'astuce
de calcul il vaut mieux retiré 400 et
ensuite à la deuxième partie donc calcul
réfléchi premier problème une classe à
moins de 30 élèves
lorsqu'on regroupe les élèves par 4 ou
pas cette il ne reste pas d'élèves seul
combien d'élèves compte sept classes une
classe à moins de 30 élèves
deuxième problème si aurait dit prends
une douche elle consomme 50 litres doux
si elle prend un bain elle consomme 160
litres
quelle quantité d'eau économise tél en
une semaine
si elle prend une douche chaque jour
[Musique]
c'est la bonne réponse alors on va
enchaîner maintenant sur l'activité
montage qui va être
présenté sur les gros ordinateurs vous
allez avoir transmis de réflexion et
vous pouvez bien sûr prendre de notes
c'est parti
sacré 75 m ce n'est pas la bonne réponse
et le temps est alors ici eu l'astuce
s'il fallait repérer on avait trois
tours de circuit simple de suture de 6,3
+5 ça fait 8
il suffisait donc de faire simplement
une addition pour le cadeau de faire
donc 2 875 plus 3625 pour trouver donc
un total de 5000 vie 100 m voilà il
fallait bien repéré donc cette deuxième
manche il est 6ème va maintenant
commencer et je vais demander le calme
deux candidats de se présenter
[Musique]
alors on démarre avec lesquels tomatis
premier exercice
combien font 75% de 400
[Musique]
combien font 75 x 102 400 attention à
bien prendre le temps de réfléchir avant
le deuxième exercice pas combien faut-il
divisé 57 pour obtenir 3 pas combien
faut-il divisé 57 pour obtenir 3
c'est très bien c'est marquant son
troisième exercice entre parenthèses
7027 +3 diable 73 x 9
donc on va pas c'est donc la deuxième
partie un calcul réfléchi premier
problème
serge achète 12 cactus à 7 euros pièce
et trois au kid est à 24 euros pièce
quel est le montant de ses dépenses
c'est hachette 12 capes tus à 7 euros
pièce chf 12 capes tus à 7 euros pièce
et 3 ans id à 24 euros pièce quel est le
montant de sa dépense
cent cinq ans 6 face à 20 6 euros 150
pièces deuxième problème pour créer une
mosaïque collective
on a acheter 180 carreaux de deux
centimètres carrés on répartit
équitablement les carreaux entre 30
enfants calcul l'air en centimètres
carrés que chaque enfant aura pour
couvrir avec ses carreaux pour créer une
mosaïque collective
on a acheter 180 carreau à deux
centimètres carrés on répartit
équitablement les carreaux entre 30
enfants calcul l'air en centimètres
carrés que chaque enfant aura pour
couvrir avec ses carreaux donc
l'activité mentale qui vous est proposée
va être déterminante
c'est d'abord nous transformons nos
réflexions
il faut rajouter fois dit oui doit
répondre surtout trois places mais 60 39
66 la bonne réponse tu marques un point
[Musique]
bravo 2
donc nous allons c'est maintenant la
troisième manche chez disnat en hausse
car neuf du collège dimidiouk est ce que
tous les deux vous êtes prêts c'est
parti donc pour les trois calcul
automatique premier exercice entre
parenthèses 8 10 8 + 2 2 x entre
parenthèses 37 - 24 entre parenthèses
8,8 plus 2,2 x entre parenthèses 37 - 24
[Musique]
deuxième exercice
combien vaut le cinquième de 360
75 ce n'est pas la bonne réponse et le
temps et malheureusement et les vingt
s'étaient 72 et oui c'était 72 un
conseil pour diviser par 5
on divise d'abord par dix et on me dit
qui part de celles aussi troisième
exercice
combien y at-il de centimètres carrés
dans 3,1 m car il sait très bien
premier problème un robinet fuit en
trois minutes 5 litres d'eau sont
gaspillées
quelle quantité d'eau en litres est
perdu en une heure un robinet fuit en
trois minutes 5 litres d'eau sont
gaspillées quelle quantité d'eau en
litres est perdu en une heure deuxième
problème un candidat à une élection a
obtenu 25% des voix
sachant que 16400 électeurs se sont
exprimés
combien ont voté pour lui
k pays ce n'est pas ma maman et bruce
4100 c'est la bonne manière et soeurs
électeurs visible tu marques un point on
enchaîne donc sur l'activité montagne
vous allez avoir trente secondes de
réflexion vous pouvez bien sûr prendre
des notes
c'est parti
le temps est écoulé visiblement ça ne
vous a pas trop inspiré vous avez ici
deux triangles rectangles ici il faut
voir les traits en même temps que
mettant fin à l'ère d'un trio en mi
temps comme étant la moitié de l'air
d'un rectangle
vous avez ici un premier qui ont
librement selleck 5 et 12 pour les deux
côtés l'angle droit donc 5 x 2 60 et on
divise par deux sacrés 30 on faire une
chose elles veulent client qu'après 4 6
3 dans lequel x 3 12 / 2,6 et 38,6 a
fait un total de 36 centimètres carrés
et ce n'était pas si difficile que ça et
[Musique]
félicitations à tous les deux et bravo
donc à tous les participants de cette
finale
[Musique]